wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
schau mal hier
wer schenkt wem was ich mache mal ein
beispiel ich schenke dir einen stift ok
jetzt ich schenke dir ein wörterbuch
vielen dank dass du gut gemacht weiter
gehts was schenkst du deinem vater
moment okay
der vater ist ein maskulines nomen das
personalpronomen heißt er jetzt brauche
ich die daten vom für er genau ihm also
ich schenke ihm ein ticket fürs theater
prima mache ich weiter
was schenkst du deiner mutter zum
geburtstag ich schenke ihr eine dvd sehr
gut und was schenkst du mi co
[Musik]
also selber eine letzte frage wen lädst
du zu deinem geburtstag einladen moment
einladen
benutzt man mit akkusativ also ich lade
dich sehr gut und vielen dank ich kann
jetzt einladungsschreiben für meinen
geburtstag
wann hast du den geburtstag in ein paar
wochen ach was hast du schon etwas
geplant ich würde gerne eislaufen gehen
eines laufen ja das habe ich noch nie
gemacht ich möchte es mal ausprobieren
können wir uns noch ja sagen ja wie geht
es ihnen denn hat er den job bekommen ja
er arbeitet jetzt sehr gut ja wir sind
fertig für heute bis zum nächsten mal
sie können stolz auf ihre tochter sein
ich fand's